[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior et l'ensemble des élus se sont
donné rendez vous à la mairie de cilaos
ce vendredi 28 septembre où s'est tenue
la commission permanente
plusieurs rapports ont été votés rapport
important qui concerne la commémoration
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
cent soixante dix ans donc nous allons
en fin d'année à partir du 20 décembre
et si albert ii n ont porté donc
l'information au plus loin des
réunionnais
concernant cette abolition de
l'esclavagé c'est un devoir de mémoire
que nous avons mais nous avons aussi
validé beaucoup d'autres rapports
notamment dans le domaine du sport de la
culture et je pense aussi de leur
partenariat avec les communes et bien
sûr des rapports qui concerne le monde
agricole
toutes ces préoccupations que porte le
département ont été validés à
l'unanimité
la délégation s'est ensuite rendue à la
station thermale de cilaos afin d'y
célébrer ses 30 ans
lieu emblématique niche au coeur du
cirque l'établissement reste néanmoins
déficitaire
le président du département et le maire
de cilaos font un pari sur l'avenir en
relançant un projet abandonné depuis 18
ans aujourd'hui nous avons confié la
quasi dépôts et consignations une étude
qui est temps pour qui veut à nous être
remis bientôt et apprécié de cette étude
nous allons l'ancien nouvelle à projets
c'est-à-dire que nous demanderons à des
opérateurs économiques bak s'ils sont
intéressés pour reprendre et il y en
aura forcément quoi repose la gestion de
l'hôtel des thermes en lien avec la
station thermale nous voulons faire une
offre touristique à travers la station
thermale et ce bâtiment de l'hôtel des
thermes
c'est grâce à l'établissement thermal
que si l'ars a connu un élan
touristique est aussi économique au fil
de ces années nous avons senti un
certain ralentissement
et aujourd'hui nous voulons que cet
établissement retrouve toutes ses
lettres de noblesse composé de 24 agents
dont deux infirmières et 8 agents de
soins l'établissement thermal repose sur
deux pôles d'activité celui de cures
thermales et celui de remise en forme
nous avons ici un potentiel
pharmacologique avec les eaux minérales
qui est important et nous faisons dans
cet établissement thermal quelquefois
j'emploie le mot à bon escient
quelquefois des miracles sur des malades
qui présentent une maladie chronique
mais le maire de cilaos a profité de la
visite du président du département pour
lui présenter le chantier en cours du
chemin pense d'abord à bras sec financé
par le pacte de solidarité territoriale
signé en juin dernier
[Musique]